we're looking at the cost of the war in
Ukraine a cost that can be seen
everywhere in that country and it's
growing every day take a look at the
latest evidence of violence what's left
of a building in a city occupied by
Russia hit by Ukrainian Rockets Ukraine
saying it was a Russian base that
building there what was this morning
amid all that destruction we are
focusing on the youngest victims of the
war Ukrainian children trying to go to
school and live their lives despite a
lack of power and amid more than the
usual uncertainty about what their
future may hold MTS tie up has the story
this could be anywhere but the morning
School run in the Kiev suburb of bucha
is anything but normal regular power
Cuts means it's cold and dark here until
the generator kicks in bringing with it
warmth and light something in short
supply at home says eight-year-old Donna
there's no electricity
it must be really hard
it's very hard she says we're freezing
at home
despite their smile these children know
War
butcher was occupied by Russian soldiers
in the early weeks of the invasion when
bodies were left scattered on the
streets including children like Katya
matvi and Vanya who were all
memorialized on a school wall says
acting principal Irina vaschenko
every morning at 9am we have a moment of
silence she says because we must never
forget them
Russia is now ruthlessly targeting
Ukraine's energy grid leaving billions
of homes without power as temperatures
plunge below freezing
for American school teacher Diane baima
despite the hardships kids still need to
be kids
originally from Milwaukee she's lived in
Ukraine since 2014.
and better Ukrainian husband here
I kept telling my husband
if if
I was unsafe but once it happened and I
was like I'm not leaving you you saved
yeah I stayed yeah
Bima didn't only stay she also kept
teaching at her local private school
have you noticed a change in any of the
kids
yeah I think some of them are a little
more emotional and and sometimes sounds
make them nervous one of your students
Maya tell me about her
Maya's dad is is fighting in the war and
so it's important for us to give her
extra support and extra help the good
morning class how are you in the
school's English class for older
children the war isn't far from their
minds either how important is it to you
that the world helps Ukraine right now
very important so I just where we
believe in humankind
believe in humankind yeah
a Humanity ukrainians young and old have
shown time and again as this brutal War
grinds on for CBS mornings Ukraine
wow well as upsetting as it is it's
still something very comforting see
children playing and laughing yeah and
still trying to process and live their
lives but that's right no child should
have to endure what those kids are going
through cold no power you're trying to
learn which is hard enough and you're
doing it knowing your parents are
sometimes off fighting a war and you
said while we were watching that we all
have this urge to find what is normal to
us and that's all kids are doing just
trying to find one and kids are so good
at it as well they are finding moments
of just normalcy amid all of that yeah
right about that okay